Hey guys, I'm Nate
We've got something really fun for you today: A lot of you have commented, saying that we should do something from the game
Fortnite, and I thought what would be the best idea would be to build one of the weapons seen in the game. So this video
is part 1 of 2 in building the "vendor tech
rocket slammer," which I thought was just the coolest looking weapon, and I had to build it. To make sure this hammer isn't gonna hurt
anyone and so it's light enough to use, most of it's going to be made out of some EVA foam and a PVC pipe.
I've got this chunk of foam which I've already sort of made into a hammerhead shape and that's going to help me make the pattern
out of the foam for the build
I made this using some of the same techniques that I described in our video where I showed how to make some large
Mario Kart shells out of fiberglass. This is pink rigid insulation foam which is glued together
and then shaped using a handsaw and some rough grit sandpaper
I've got a couple kinds of glue, a razor blade, a heat gun, some tape; I've also got my computer up on the counter which
I'm gonna be using to look at my reference pictures of the hammer. Let's get started
Let's start with this block that I've already carved into the general shape of a hammer head
We'll cover this form in tape and then cut it off
Let's trim off the top and bottom of the tape and then use one
vertical cut to remove it from our form. As we cut and remove the sheet of tape from around our form, we can see that
it's very curved.
We'll need to add a few more cuts in it to get it to lie flat on our sheet of foam
With the cuts added into our sheet of tape, we can now press it down onto the sheet to make it lie flat.
Let's take a white marker and trace around our entire pattern down onto the foam. We can then remove the tape and cut along the
lines that we've drawn
With our pattern cut out of the foam, we now need to glue together all of the exposed edges.
I'm using contact cement,
which I'm storing in a squeeze bottle with a small hole cut in the tip. This makes for a very easy application
As we start gluing together the pattern, we can see the form of the hammer-head begin to take shape
Once we've glued together all of the matching edges, our EVA foam hammerhead is looking great
Let's move on to making the face of our hammer
We can place what we've just built face down on a mat of more foam and trace around
that with our white marker. To try and get our edges to match up nicely,
we'll cut around this circle at a 45-degree angle
Let's trim the edge of the hammer head at a 45-degree angle as well. Now the two pieces should meet nicely. By gluing those
two pieces together, we have the front face of our hammer. To help prevent the head of our hammer from deforming,
let's draw and cut out some shapes from a 1-inch sheet of styrofoam
The head of this hammer has one large 8-sided piece on top of a smaller 8-sided piece, which are both held a small
distance away from this face [that] we've already assembled
We'll cut out one of the small pieces and two of the large pieces and then put those together. Because contact cement will actually dissolve
styrofoam, we'll be using a hot glue gun to glue the styrofoam pieces together
By placing our styrofoam octagons down on sheets of foam, we can trace out
just the right sizes to completely cover all the styrofoam in the EVA foam
The center of this hammer's striking face has a domed circle on it. To get a curved surface,
let's use our heat gun on a piece of foam; and when it's nice
and hot, we'll try stretching it over a playground ball. The EVA foam can't stretch and shape infinitely,
but we can add a little bit of contour, if needed. This bowl has the right circumference for the circle
[that] we want to add onto the hammer
So let's use this to trace out a circle onto our curved foam
We can glue this domed circle onto the front of our hammer,
and we have our impact head [finished]
To add a little bit of space between the body of our hammer head and the striking face of our hammer head,
let's glue together two sheets of EBA foam and then cut a circle out from them
Once this striking face is attached to the body of the hammer,
it will be very difficult to do any cleanup work,
so let's do that quickly now. A stone grinding attachment on a rotary tool does an excellent job of taking down sharp edges on EVA foam,
and for filling in any gaps or scratches in the foam, we'll use something called gallery glass
It's a product designed to simulate the "letting" in stained glass. It does a great job of filling in gaps,
and it takes paint very well. As a final
preparation step before we attach the striking face of our hammer onto the body of the hammer head,
let's hit it with a heat gun, which will help seal the foam and make it easier to paint later on
With all that prep work complete,
let's use some more contact cement and glue the two pieces of the hammerhead together
Some of the next steps will require knowing where the handle will attach to our
hammerhead. Our handle is going to be a PVC pipe,
so let's measure and cut a hole for that. We can mark the foam by pressing the PVC into it just a little bit, and
we have a clear line where we need to cut. We're not going to permanently attach the handle yet,
because it would get in the way as we work on the rest of the hammerhead
Just like with the front of a hammer, we will trace a circle that will be glued on to the back
We'll cut this circle at a 45-degree angle and trim the back of the hammer as well, so the two angles meet up nicely
Before we glue on that circle though,
we'll build the rest of the back of the hammer onto it, as well as attach our handle and
reinforcing it inside the hammer head. The back of our hammer has a few different sizes of circles leading up to a
conical piece that is the rocket at the back of the hammer. Let's trace out those circle pieces from foam and then glue those on
Before we glue some of these circles down permanently, let's use our rotary tool to smooth down the corners
To get a custom cone shape, we can either partially cut a piece of paper or partially tape two pieces of paper together
By overlapping the edges more or less [variably], we can get a cone that is either more or less pointed
Once our paper is overlapped, to give us the shape of cone
we want, we can tape it off and then measure the size of circle for the base of the cone
I'm going to use this roll of tape to measure, because it happens to be just the right size of circle. This marker on top
Of a few stacked sheets of foam will give us a uniform height that you can trace around our cone.
After cutting off the extra, I now have a chronical strip of paper that should work as a perfect pattern.
A quick cut gives us a nice flat piece of paper that we can trace out onto a sheet of foam and then cut it out
This cone shape on the back of our hammer has some panels along the sides of it that are the same size and shape, so
we'll cut out a second one of these patterns as well. To make the side panels,
we cut one of the two pieces of foam into six equal parts. A quick cleanup with our rotary tool gives us nice rounded edges
Let's glue all six of those panels around the sides of our conical ring. After a little bit more cleanup with our rotary tool,
we're ready to glue that cone-shaped ring to the back of our hammer
The back of our rocket has a second cone shape extending off of the back of the first one
Let's use that same technique with a piece of paper to make a custom cone-shaped pattern
Once again, a roll of tape happens to be just the right size, so we'll trace off of that
Finally, the back of our rocket has another cone-shaped piece that tapers inward, rather than out.
Once again, a quick paper comb pattern to make that piece. A
small flat circle in the middle of that cone finishes up the back piece
With that glued in place, the back of our rocket hammer is looking great
The rocket portion of our rocket slammer is now built, and as I said, we aren't attaching it yet until we've really secured the handle
inside our hammer, but it's looking really good--
It's looking really good
The front is looking really good,
and so now we have four fins that we need to add going around the body, as well as two little
energy pods with a cable coming out of them.
I don't know what those are supposed to do,
but they look neat. A rubber band stretched around the body of the
hammerhead will give me a nice even line that I can measure from
Making these fins is going to take just a little bit of guesswork, so let's cut out
what looks like about the right shape and then modify it as we go
We can hold our cut fin pattern up to the body of the hammer and see where it needs adjustments
Once we have the inside contour of the fin correct, we can draw in the outside shape
The shape of this fin is good, but the fins need to be a little bit thicker,
so let's glue together two sheets of our EVA foam and then cut out four of this fin pattern
Adding these four fins is definitely going to make our hammer look more like a rocket
The sides of our rocket have two small pucks which seem to be glowing with blue energy
The surface of these pucks have three recessed cutouts, so for each one
I'll cut out a circle and then remove the unneeded
pieces from that circle. The circles with the removed pieces can then be glued onto the surface of some thicker pieces
Quickly going over the edges with the rotary tool smooths out the corners. Each of these pucks
also has a small raised circle in the middle, which will just add with a thin sheet of EBA foam
Let's glue these two pucks onto the side of the body of our rocket hammer
This rubbery gas line hose should work really well for the cables that run from the little pucks on the side of the hammer, up
to the front of the striking head
We'll hit them with a heat gun to get the shape closer to what we want. At the end of our rubber
hose, we want it to make a sharp 90-degree turn,
so we'll cut a small notch into the rubber and then add some glue to make it hold that shape
The head of our rocket hammer is mostly built, so it is time to move on
to the handle. The base of that is going to be this PVC pipe, which is just a tiny bit too long.
I think you need to take just a few inches off of the bottom,
but most of this handle is made up of a few different
cones. The head of the hammer will fit this far onto this PVC pipe to really give it some stability,
then there's sort of a cone shape underneath that, a
round cylinder under that, and then we've just got a good stretch of plane handle;
and then we've got a flared cone here and a long, tapered cone at the very bottom
Let's trim off the end of this, and then I've taken the liberty of making some of those cone shapes out of paper
We'll use those as patterns and cut them out of foam
A small ring of hot glue will hold the neck in place when I slide it up to the height that it's supposed to be
Below the cylindrical piece is another small ring,
which will just be another small strip of EVA foam. The body of the handle is mostly one uniform thickness,
but there are two recessed strips,
which run down the length of the handle [that are] angled a little bit more toward the front
So we'll coat the rest of the handle in more EVA foam, leaving a gap where those two strips should go
There are two more cones that make up the bottom handle shape of our hammer, and we'll make those the same way
we've made our other cones. A small doughnut-shaped ring can connect the opening of the upper, wider cone to the lower, narrower cone
We really want to make sure that our pipe is well-attached to the inside of the head of the rocket hammer,
so let's cut out some circles that will fit around our pipe and then glue onto the inside body of the rocket hammer,
to make sure that it's not going to move around as I shake and swing this thing
The PVC has support attaching it to the top and bottom of the inside of the rocket hammer body,
but I want even more than that, so we've got these two pieces of
supporting foam that will work as a sort of
scaffolding on the inside of the hammer.
With our support structure well installed inside the head of our hammer,
we can now glue on the back rocket. With the hammer head attached firmly onto the handle,
it's time to add the few pieces that connect the neck of the hammer onto the head
Once again, these pieces are thicker than a single sheet of foam, so it's glue two of them together.
Because of where some of these supporting pieces attach,
it's necessary to do a little bit of cleanup on the hammer head using our rotary tool
At this point, all of the pieces are added onto our hammer
There's nothing left to do as far as the build goes. Of course, this doesn't look like the hammer in the game because we haven't
added paint to it yet
So there are some little details that will need to be carved into the foam, and then we'll go through a several step process
to paint this whole thing up, but it is looking great
Hey guys
We've still got more for you to see
There's a little box at the top that will transport you directly to our last video
Go check it out
The box at the bottom is the one that YouTube thinks that you should be watching next, and this bomb here in the middle will
Subscribe you to our channel, so you never get left out again!
Don't forget to ring the bell and we'll see you next time talk to you then!